good morning belief nation today's
message is start now over to you Jocko
willing people want to know how to stop
the laziness and they won't know how to
stop the procrastination and you know
they have some idea in their head you
know some kind of a vision what they
want to do but they don't know where to
start in order to start it you know they
don't know where to start and say they
say hey where do I start
and and when's the best time to start
and I have a very simple answer for that
here and now that's it you you want to
improve you want to get better you want
to get on a workout program or a clean
diet you want to start a business you
want to write a book or make a movie or
build a house or a computer or put
together some mobile application where
do you start you start right here and
when do you start you start right now
you initiate the action aggressively you
go because the idea isn't gonna execute
itself and the book isn't gonna write
itself and the waits out in the gym
they're not gonna move themselves you
have to do it and you have to do it now
and that means you gotta stop thinking
about it and stop dreaming about it and
stop researching every aspect of it and
reading all about it and debating the
pros and cons of it just start doing it
take
first step and make it happen get after
it and get after it here and now there
is no perfect first step there is no
perfect plan there is no perfect time to
get started a lot of people are so held
up on finally what the perfect first
thing is to do that they do nothing and
that's the ultimate failure the ultimate
failure is doing nothing and just
sitting on this idea and never taking
any kind of action for it because you're
worried about making misstep you're
worried about making mistake you're
worried that is not perfect your
perfectionism is killing you it's
preventing you from doing amazing things
in your life and with the business you
take any step you have a vision here's
what I want to accomplish here's my goal
I want to write a book I want to start a
company I want to whatever it is
whatever first step comes to mind go and
do that and then adjust adjust adjust
adjust you can have the best plan in the
world right and I'm all for business
planning it's not just I'm just gonna
throw an idea out there and see what
happens right you can plan you can model
success you can look at what has worked
for people but you have to go out and do
it because the best plan is obsolete as
soon as you start executing on it and
this is what almost killed my first
business this is how I have learned the
lesson because I was that guy I was too
perfectionist I didn't want to do
anything so I had it all figured out and
you only later realize that what you
think you figured out you have no idea
what you're talking about because you
haven't gone out and done anything yet I
lost a 40 million dollar deal in my
first company I was making $300 a month
sucking in my company turns it around
started making an income and had an
opportunity to sell my business for 40
million dollars and I lost it to my
biggest competitor because I had to have
the perfect plan because I spent an
entire summer working on the perfect
plan and that was too late to the table
I was looking the wrong way what made
great sense on paper wasn't actually
what was gonna happen in the market and
I lost a 40 million dollar dude because
of it
that kills that sucks I was 22 years old
it's important to plan what you need to
do and don't get so hung up on having
the perfect step don't worry what the
first step is people write in and say
what's my first it doesn't matter
something do something and then do
something again tomorrow and do
something again the next day and every
day you get a little bit better start
taking massive action that's how you're
gonna get that idea out of your head
finally and out into the worlds you can
start reaping the benefits and having a
big impact on this world like you are
meant to do so the question is a today
is I'm curious what are you afraid to
start now that you're going to as a
result of watching this video leave it
down in the comments below I'm really
curious to find out I also want to give
a quick shout out to on Yammer Oriakhi
thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book your one word really really
really means a lot to me and hope you're
enjoying the read thank you guys again
for watching
I believe in you if we continue to
believe in yourself
and whatever you're one where it is and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot events press I love when I
want my my assistants got a great thing
now in this once in every four months
somebody sends an email saying I've got
a huge startup that I want you to invest
in but you've gotta sign this NDA right
which literally every time gets an email
back that says you write and and the
reason is I'm a humongous believer that
ideas are [ __ ] and that executions the
game right we've all got ideas
everybody's got ideas doing ideas we all
have here we can probably sit here for
the next two hours draw them all out
record them and predict the next 78
great startups over the next nine years
and so I think the thing that is another
theme in entrepreneurship is there is
way too much fodder brought to the idea
Hoover was magic cab three years earlier
not an idea who ever existed it's called
magic cab but the guys that executed
sucked so they lost so I think you know
if there's any level of romance left in
this room about your idea
I'd like to suffocate it because I think
the actual situation is what you
actually do with it as a musician you
want to be great like you want to be
good and you sort of set these funny
expectations for yourself you know one
of the funniest things that the Fogerty
ever said to me he was like yeah I was I
tried to learn I was learning to play
the drums but I realized that I would
never be as good as John Bonham from Led
Zeppelin so I stopped Mike who is as
good as John but nobody liked what the
rock how could you do that so like there
should be no right or wrong you know you
should just be cool with what you do and
how you sound like I'm it's it's one of
the things that I have a problem with
like a lot of those song contest shows
on TV not not only because you know
whatever its corporate cheese or
whatever but I have a problem with like
if my kid walked up on stage and sang
her heart out as best as she could and
Jennifer Lopez said like nah sorry
that's not good enough
I'd be like I'll be so pissed you know
cuz that's not how it works you know you
should be you should go you should go to
a yard sale and buy a she'll guitar and
then go find a friend and get into your
garage and just suck there'd be awful
and then write some songs and become the
biggest band in the world that's how
it's that's how it works I mean it works
other ways to I'm sure but I mean as a
as a young musician you know first of
all you're not gonna make a living doing
it like except that realize that because
then if you do stopped
the reward of playing music playing
music should be the reward of playing
music like that's that's what you that's
what you kind of get like when I was a
little kid when I was playing punk rock
music as a teenager like there was never
any career opportunity because we played
punk rock music nobody wanted to buy
that but we'd love to do it it was so it
was so much fun and like if you start
from a place like that that you just
love to create and you just love to play
music and you can't stop thinking about
it and you do it every day and you do it
by yourself or you do it with your
friends and that's enough for you to
survive the rest of your life that's
great and then once you start getting
good you start playing for people and
once you start playing for people if
you're good then those people will tell
other people that girl's really good so
then all of a sudden you're playing to
all these different people and that to
me is the most important thing when you
doing it's you on stage and people are
seeing when people see another person
doing that it's really inspiring like
it's cool to see a human being
jamming that's great I was very
headstrong young person and by 1980 3 or
4 had started my own publishing company
to publish my own books realizing that
no one else will publish me and I was
right about that and so my first book I
saved my food money from Black Flag a
little here little there and I saved
enough to make a fold and staple book I
couldn't type so I hand write up the
things and I made a dummy then I could
offset print fold and staple and I sold
them for $2 mainly gave them away but I
sold enough and they blew out 500 just
went and then I took that money to make
another print run of that and from that
money I made my first paper back and 33
years later that's a fully staffed
company with books in translation and
hardcover editions and the whole you
know the whole nine yards but it started
with I'm gonna do
my thing I'll be city lights jr. without
the talent and that's I did that at the
same time I was doing my first spoken
word gigs and why did I have the
gumption and the audacity to start my
own book company because I come from
punk rock I come from watching Ian
MacKaye invent Dischord records on his
mom's kitchen table I come from folding
and gluing picture sleeves together
black flag had their own label of course
you'd do it yourself you want to make a
book sit down and write it then go to
the printing place where's a printer get
in the phone book and find a printer we
make records make some books it was you
just do it it's like you don't even
think about you just do it and I'm sure
that writing is this awful but I did it
and without even hesitation I'm making
my own book companies stop me I dare you
I've never thought about it twice just
because DIY man like let your voice be
heard